la frc a le département de la réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la réunion nous
présente terre d'ici
pour
de juillet à décembre durant la campagne
sucrière l'usiné du gol ouvre ses portes
au public du mardi au samedi sur
réservation les visiteurs peuvent ainsi
découvrir tout le process de
transformation de la canne entière au
sucre fini la visite en fait est
décomposée en trois parties on a une
première partie où on va diffuser un
petit film qui explique un petit peu le
process sucrier ça c'est la première
partie deuxième partie on va équiper les
gens avec une charlotte pour l'hygiène
un casque pour la sécurité et un audio
guide qui permet d'entendre
très bien toute la visite et ensuite on
part pour la visite qui dure à peu près
une heure quinze dans l'usiné l'idée ça
va être de suivre la can pour voir sa
transformation de cannes jusqu'en jusqu
en sucre voilà ça va durer à peu près
une heure quinze et ensuite on rentre à
la boutique et là on vous fait une
petite dégustation de produits sucrés de
rome de confiserie tout ce qui est lié
en fait à la can mais avant sa place à
la visite de la sucrerie après leur
réception
les cannes sont broyés pour en extraire
le jus clarifier tout d'abord le jus de
canne sucre et et concentré petit à
petit jusqu'à obtenir un sirop épais de
couleur caramel le fameux sirop la cuite
français
la visite se poursuit à l'intérieur de
l'imposante structure jusqu'au poste de
commande centralisé de la sucrerie
c'est ici que les opérateurs j'avais le
bon fonctionnement de tout le process de
fabrication du sucre toute la chaîne
opératoire du sucre
tous ces ordinateurs est un petit peu
comme le cerveau de la sucrerie
on va leur permettre de contrôler des
niveaux de contrôle id
température par exemple voir la quantité
de jus qui en deux ans n'est pas pour
water on va leur permettre d'intervenir
pour ouvrir des vannes pour fermer les
vannes
un peu plus loin nos visiteurs ont
encore droit à une séance de dégustation
de sucre cette fois ci
3d
au vol pour être vaccinés en sucre
il faut bien celui là
réponse qui devrait être parfait celui
questionné par la chaleur par le bruit
par
les machines
parce que parce que j'apprécie aussi
c'est que tout est recyclé tous rsa
c'est fantastique il n'y a pas de
déchets pour le problème moi j'aime le
rhum le roma pas à base de mélasse c'est
dommage mais le sucre est excellent donc
voilà je trouve ça hyper intéressant des
rom et des produits à base de sucre que
les visiteurs peuvent découvrir et
déguster plus précisément à la boutique
de lusine est franchement elle et il est
bon il est très très parfumée toutefois
avec modération bien sûr
bien sûr il ya des différentes
modération arrêt modération beaucoup
parti pour la visite c'est parti pour la
visite sous la lumière des projecteurs
c'est une atmosphère particulière que
les visiteurs viennent découvrir ce soir
là à bois rouge comme son homologue de
saint louis
la sucrerie de saint-andré propose
également durant la campagne sucrière
des visites nocturnes guidée de ses
installations
donc on explique un petit peu le
l'arrivée de la canne à sucre
quelqu'un a su très concernés on est
assez l'est de l'île dont on explique
comment fonctionne la plate forme de
réception et après on commence avec les
10'' les différentes étapes de
transformation
donc on va vraiment surtout le
cheminement pendant toute la visite
ensuite toutes les étapes de la
transformation de la fibre de canne est
le fil conducteur c'est vraiment la
fibre de canne en elle-même donc du
début jusqu'à la fin
c'est ça qu'on essaye de suivre au début
du procès ce sucrier la can et des
fibres et après d'en extraire le maximum
de jus une opération réalisée à
l'intérieur
diffuseur d'être aussi on voit les
libres 2 canaux m6 votre cas n'est
qu'elle retrouve un peu de jus pour
extraire le pour extraire le
le sucre en fait le sucre de la can
voilà c'est assez fait on voit bien que
c'est imprégnés de liquides et ça ça
cool ça cool assez vite quoi on a déjà
mais trop souvent de d'imaginer le sucre
et vengeance traction adorent ça
tout au long de la visite les touristes
découvrent ainsi les différentes étapes
du procédé d'extraction du sucre de
canne jusqu'à la phase finale
c'est quasiment l'étape cruciale en fait
la cristallisation c'est là qu'on va
retirer le sucre qui est dans le quai
dans le jus et
donc c'est là qu'on va obtenir ce qu'on
appelle le titre ruf le sucre de canne
et donc le sucre qui est très apprécié à
la réunion puisque en général c'est le
sucre de tous les jours le sucre ou le
sucre de cap
la visite du site industriel de bois
rouge se poursuit à la distillerie de
savanna attenante à la découverte du
procédé de fabrication des différents
types de rome après un passage par le
chai de vieillissement
la visite s'achève à la boutique par une
dégustation des différents produits
c'est un homme métis pur esprit
l'aromatiser avec ainsi on retrouve la
passion c'est le pur c'est l'europe des
pirates
tout un programme c'est toujours mieux
de réserver à l'avancé puisque on a
quand même pas mal de monde surtout en
saison puisqu'on a quand même des
des groupes limités par personne et puis
il ya aussi des visites qui se font
visites scolaires visites de groupes
visite des comités d'entreprise compte
après il faut vraiment s'adresser à la
boutique tafia égal à b pour avoir tous
ces informations
dans